it's not just cops getting cancelled by
the way which is too bad because I was
thought that was a great great show one
of the early reality TV shows even one
of the great films of all time gone with
the wind is being cancelled because it
depicts the South in the 19th century
and that is very politically incorrect
and so it's being pulled from HBO max
and there's a real irony to this which
is that the movie Gone with the Wind
depicting the 19th century South
actually played an important role in the
development of racial relations in the
country because Hattie McDaniel the
black actress and Gone with the Wind won
an Oscar broke a barrier for her
performance I just listened to her
introduction at the Oscar ceremony which
was much more bearable at the time much
you know back in those days it wasn't
all glitz and glamor and Jimmy Kimmel it
was they kept thing as much shorter was
much more humble but listen to this
beautiful introduction and a recognition
that her winning the Oscar was an
important step in American race
relations to me it seems and more than
just a plaque of gold it opens the doors
of this room moves back the world and it
Able's us to embrace the whole of
America an America that we love an
America that almost alone in the world
today recognizes and pays tribute to
those who give their best regardless of
creed race or color it is with the
knowledge that this entire nation will
stand and salute the presentation of
this plaque that I resent the Academy
Award for the best performance of an
actress in supporting role during 1939
the head of a gang
listen to that introduction what we're
being told by the left now is that
everybody before yesterday everyday
everybody before we our wonderful selves
were born was hopelessly bigoted and
racist and terrible and now it's up to
us to tear down their statues if we want
to continue to be good people that
introduction was very self-aware that
introduction was aware that there was a
race problem in America and there were
concrete steps you could take to
ameliorate that race problem to to bring
people together and this this is true
going back a long way if you go back all
the way to the Declaration of
Independence Declaration of Independence
written by that terrible guide Thomas
Jefferson who is a mean old racist who
is so much worse than we are you see
that Americans at the time understood
there was a race problem there was this
peculiar institution of slavery that a
lot of people really didn't like and
that everybody recognized was foisting a
very difficult dilemma on the American
colonies and they they complained about
it you know in the Declaration of
Independence they're complaining about
this and trying to work their way
through it that kind of nuance is lost
when you're when you're in the business
of tearing down statues so how do you
McDaniel gets up there first black woman
to win an Academy Award is her speech
about how it's damn well about time a
black woman wins an Academy Award and
all you people in the room who gave it
to me are terrible bigoted racists no
not quite
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Science fellow members of the motion
picture industry and honored guests this
is one of the happiest moments of my
life and I want to thank each one of you
who had a part in selecting me for one
of the awards for your kindness it has
made me feel very very humble and I
shall always hold it as a beacon for
anything that I may be able to do in the
future I sincerely hope I shall always
be a credit to my race and to the motion
picture industry my heart is too full to
tell you just how for you and may I say
thank you
so this is one of the great acceptance
speeches in the history of the Oscars
and most notably because it was short a
bad Peck in these days people had class
and decorum so they knew not to make
their rambling speeches go on for 10
minutes they kept it - I think Hattie
McDaniel did it for a minute or 90
seconds but you heard what she said she
used phrases that are very politically
incorrect she was the first she said I
hope to be a credit to my race not that
phrase you certainly couldn't say
anymore but what is in that phrase what
is in that phrase is an acknowledgement
of the racial significance of this
moment and to say I I hope that that I
am representing my race in a good way
just as the presenter was representing
her race in a good way imagine if the
presenter came out and said you know she
was wearing a Ku Klux Klan hood and you
know she made some sort of bigoted
comments that woman would not have been
a credit to her race but what this is
representing is a moment of coming
together to people recognizing their
significance the Academy Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences recognizing the
significance of this and trying to help
American race relations and then the
words use that's probably even less
popular now is humble humility you're
not allowed to be humble anymore we've
got to be prideful pride which we've
always considered to be the queen of all
vices the queen of all sins is now
considered the paragon of virtue but
humility is a lot better than pride when
you consider the great saints of history
do you do you remember them for their
pride or their humility if you if you're
familiar with the real Saints then it's
probably the humility st. John Vianney
st. Francis of Assisi st. Thomas Aquinas
one of the most intelligent brilliant
minds ever to exist on earth was known
for his humility at the at the end of
his life after Thomas Aquinas had
written the greatest works of theology
of philosophy ever written Thomas
Aquinas after a religious vision said
everything that I have written seems
like so much straw to me now compared to
what I've seen all of my efforts my
humble efforts have been really nothing
compared to the to the immensity of God
himself a perfect example of humility
even
secular Saints even if you reject the
real Saints and you just you're just
talking about political Saints or left
you know leftists answer secular Saints
I think of guys like Gandhi or Nelson
Mandela these these are people who are
really by the secular culture considered
some of the greatest men to ever live
well what are those guys are known for
their humility not their pride Gandhi in
particular puts forward this image of
humility and Nelson Mandela you know the
guy was imprisoned for a long time
Nelson Mandela was involved in some very
radical radical left-wing politics which
is why conservatives have a little bit
of an issue with him but when he came
out of prison he represented a political
humility of political healing a
political coming together that's what we
want that's what we need more of if you
want to come together and heal as a
country you need that sort of thing but
unfortunately humility along with going
with the wind has been cancelled
[Music]
[Music]